على الرغم من كونه الرئيس الأول والوحيد
في التاريخ الذي يتم عزله
مرتين ، لا يزال الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
هو الأوفر حظًا إذا ترشح مرة أخرى في عام
2024 على الأقل إذا سألت السناتور ميت
رومني
رومني كان بالطبع السناتور الجمهوري الوحيد الذي
صوت لإدانة الرئيس.  الرئيس
في كلتا محاكمات عزله ، لكن
إليكم ما قاله في نيويورك تايمز.
لا أعرف ما إذا كان سيترشح في عام 2024 أم لا ،
لكن إذا فعل ،
فأنا متأكد من أنه سيفوز
بالترشيح ،
فأنا ألقي نظرة على استطلاعات الرأي  وتظهر استطلاعات الرأي
أنه من بين الأسماء التي تم طرحها
كمنافسين محتملين في عام 2024 ،
إذا وضعت الرئيس ترامب هناك
بين الجمهوريين ، فقد فاز بأغلبية ساحقة ،
دعني أنتقل إلى كبيرة المحللين السياسيين في
CNN جلوريا بورغر غلوريا التي نعلم أن
ترامب يتجه إلى السياسة المحافظة السنوية
يقال إن مؤتمر لجنة العمل cpac في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
لإثبات أنه مرشح 2024
المفترض ، ولكن فقط استمع
إلى هذه اللحظة المحرجة جدًا على التل
اليوم مع
اثنين من الجمهوريات.  ديرس في المنزل ،
نعم ، يجب عليه
نعم ، الأمر متروك لـ cpac لقد قمت بتوضيح
آرائي حول
الرئيس ترامب ، لا أعتقد
أنه يجب أن يلعب دورًا في
مستقبل الحفلة للبلد
في هذا المستوى العالي  ملاحظة شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا